[Musique]
bonsoir à tous retour de l'information
locale en 26 minutes sur tv 78 bienvenue
dans ce set 8 journal tout de suite les
titres de ce lundi 7 janvier l'acte 1 8
de la mobilisation des gilet jaune un
rassemblement pacifique s'est tenue
samedi aux clayes-sous-bois un week end
une fois encore émaillé en d'autres
lieux par la violence notamment à paris
où un ministère a été pris pour cible
invité le député des yvelines jean noël
barrot tout récent secrétaire général du
modem après les gilet jaune les stylos
rouges un mouvement de professeurs en
colère née sur les réseaux sociaux et
sans syndicat il avec l'âme de meilleurs
salaires et conditions de travail des
actions concrètes étaient prévues dans
les établissements ce jour de rentrée
des classes
réaction au plateau avec delphine romani
secrétaire snes fsu des yvelines et puis
nous a quittés le 1er octobre dernier
charles aznavour repose depuis dans les
yvelines dans le caveau familial de
montfort l'amaury est la commune est
devenue un lieu de pèlerinage pour les
fans du chanteur reportage assure
également première rétrospective de la
semaine sur les faits marquants de l'an
passé et un point sur les grands rendez
vous sportifs de 2019 dans les yvelines
une nouvelle mobilisation donc ce week
end et gilet jaune aux clayes-sous-bois
la manifestation se voulait pacifique et
convivial avec les automobilistes et
notamment le partage de la
traditionnelle galette le reportage d'
or ils iront et 2 marylène yapi chinon
concert de klaxons samedi au rond-point
de la résistance aux clayes-sous-bois à
l'appel d'une dizaine de gilet jaune
un huitième acte pacifique pour montrer
au gouvernement qu'ils sont toujours
aussi déterminés nous
voulons en fait tout simplement nous
mouvements des gilet jaune des claies et
alentour mobiliser le maximum faire des
opérations forte pour que la france
puisse entendre qu'il ya aussi un
mobilisation il n'y a pas seulement qu'à
part et il ya aussi en région dont dans
les yvelines
ballard au sommet sur une voie pour
bloquer un petit peu la circulation pour
pouvoir dire aux gens qu'on est là quand
jura + jour là qu'il faut qu'ils
s'assurent qu'ils viennent nous
rejoindre
les manifestantes également rendu
hommage aux personnes blessées ou
décédées depuis le début de la
mobilisation actions moins solennelle en
ce week-end de l'épiphanie une
distribution de galettes des rois
étaient organisées auprès des
automobilistes
[Musique]
ça n'est pas allé jusqu'au du serment
parce qu'il y en a qui veulent durcir
c'est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas fait pour
mais oui je pense que ça va amener à
quelque chose j'espère en tout cas s'il
faut être là tous les samedis au mois de
janvier février mars on lui sera alors
que le grand débat national doit
s'ouvrir dans les prochains jours les
gilet jaune des clayes-sous-bois
semblent déterminés à poursuivre leur
mobilisation
toujours dans la convivialité un acte 8d
gilet jaune qui n'a pas été pacifiques
en tous les endroits vous avez vu
sûrement ces images d'un boxeur frappant
des gendarmes celle aussi de l'assaut
mené contre le ministère du porte parole
du gouvernement benjamin griveaux
bonsoir jean noël barrot pour ça vous
êtes le député de la 2e circonscription
des yvelines tout récemment nommé comme
secrétaire général du modem on en parle
dans un instant que vous inspire déjà ce
huitième acte d de la mobilisation des
gilet jaune émaillé encore une fois par
par des violences oui je regrette
d'abord que un certain nombre de
débordements et eu lieu et des
comportements inacceptables notamment
vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre et je
veux redire tout mon soutien au gendarme
aux policiers aux pompiers qui ont pris
sur leurs marques vacances parfois sur
leur temps personnel pour être présent
lors des différentes journées de
manifestations pour assurer la sécurité
et je souhaite que les violences
s'arrêtent désormais et face à ce
nouveau week-end de violences le premier
ministre edouard philippe fera des
annonces d'ordre public ce soir dans le
jt de tf1
peut-être celle de créer un fichier pour
identifier les individus qui frappe les
forces de l'ordre
écoutez à ce propos une autre députée
des yvelines aurore bergé invité ce
matin sur lci mesure policiers je
pensais turelli d'ailleurs je pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin on interdit
bien d'entrer dans les stades
celles et ceux dont on sait qu'ils sont
ce qu'on appelle les hooligans et c'est
à dire qu'ils auront des comportements
délictueux et violent et bien moi je
pense qu'en effet on peut aller plus
loin c'est à dire un manque qui est un
fichier qui permettent d'identifier
celles et ceux dont on sait qu de
manière récurrente
ils sont là pour casser pour frapper des
policiers et des gendarmes pour attenter
à les symboles républicains pour
travailler aussi parfois d'autres
manifestants pour les interdire de
manifester
jean-noël barrot y faut une réponse
forte ce soir du gouvernement je crois
qu'il ya un principe simple le peuple
est souverain
le président de la république l'a
rappelé il élit des représentants lors
des élections
ces représentants votent des lois et les
lois doivent être respectées
celui qui s'en prend un maître d'école
celui qui s'en prend un agent de police
ou un gendarme
il piétine la volonté du sou du peuple
souverain et piétine la loi et doit être
sanctionnée en fonction alors il ya eu
des pas fait par le gouvernement est ce
que vous pensez que la sortie de crise
va être dans ce grand débat national qui
va débuter le 15 janvier une grande
consultation nationale avec des réunions
locales des contributions également sur
une plateforme numérique est ce que
c'est ça la solution
je crois d'abord que le premier pas
c'était d'apporter un certain nombre de
réponses immédiates avec l'annulation de
la hausse des taxes sur le carburant et
puis le plan de 10 milliards d'euros
pour la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
la suppression de la hausse de la csg
pour 5 millions de retraités
la prime de noël et puis maintenant le
grand débat qui va s'ouvrir et
permettent de faire émerger un certain
nombre de solutions concrètes pour
apporter des réponses aux problèmes des
français et comment ça va s'organiser
dans les yvelines ce ce débat vous ai
fait parvenir aujourd'hui une lettre au
maire des yvelines pour leur demander de
s'associer dans cette démarche de débat
national comment ça va se mettre en
place dans les yvelines
le président de la république a annoncé
qu'il écrirait à toutes les françaises
et tous les français pour leur indiquer
comment il souhaitait que ce débat
puisse avoir lieu dès que ces conditions
seront connus nous nous associerons les
députés avec les autres aux élus et
toutes les citoyennes et citoyens et les
la société civile organisée c'est à dire
les mouvements les associations qui
souhaitent prendre part à ce débat pour
que les propositions émergent et qu'elle
puisse donner lieu à des propositions
concrètes et président de la république
doit envoyer une lettre aux français
voilà pour cadrer ce grand débat
national jean noël barrot vous avez été
nommé par le président du modem françois
bayrou comme secrétaire général du parti
c'était en décembre vous succédez à
wigan wehrling vous qui est déjà député
des yvelines vice président de la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale comment vous avez accueilli
cette nouvelle fonction c'est un honneur
que d'être désigné à cette fonction
associe une exigence parce que vous
l'avez rappelé g j'ai mon mandat de
parlementaire que jeu que je compte bien
continuer à assumer pleinement fait
compliqué de faire coïncider tous les
emplois du temps il va falloir y
travailler la mission du secrétaire
général c'est d'animer le mouvement à la
fois dans les fédérations
départementales mais aussi de faire
rayonner le mouvement au delà pour qu'il
puisse porter un message et apporter sa
contribution au projet de la majorité
présidentielle à laquelle il appartient
mais quand même quelles sont vos
ambitions à ce poste comment continuer
de faire porter cette aide doit du
centre aujourd'hui on a écouté le
mouvement démocrate a une longue
histoire de participation à la vie
politique française
il doit aujourd'hui comme tous les
mouvements politiques se réinventer pour
apporter je dirai ce que les citoyens
lui demande c'est à dire une nouvelle
manière de participer de s'exprimer dans
le débat public
les vieilles recettes des partis
politiques ont été rejetées en masse
dans les dernières élections donc il
nous revient à nous responsables de
partis politiques dont je pense je
continue de penser qu'ils sont
absolument nécessaires pour structurer
le débat où ils n'auraient ils nous il
nous revient de créer des nouveaux modes
d'expression pour les citoyennes et
citoyens la france est dans la stratégie
qu'elle est elle c'est de rester dans
cette alliance avec la république en
marche qui a été mise en place depuis
2010 est il ya deux ministres modem au
gouvernement une soixantaine de
il ya trois ministres pardon modem au
gouvernement une soixante et une
quarantaine pardon de députés modem à
l'assemblée nationale
il faut rester dans cette stratégie
d'alliance oui bien sûr le l'alliance
que françois bayrou a offerte à proposer
à emmanuel macron a sans doute permis la
victoire d'emmanuel macron nous sommes
partie prenante un certain nombre de
réformes qui ont déjà été entreprises et
nous comptons bien rester au coeur de
cette majorité présidentielle pour faire
valoir les valeurs qui me sont chères et
ça sera du coup la même stratégie
adoptée en vue du prochain scrutin qui
sont les européennes le 26 mai prochain
il vous allez y aller avec votre allié
de la république on marche
je crois que le souhait qui est
largement partagée c'est qu'il puisse y
avoir une liste commune pour défendre
des valeurs notamment la promotion de
l'union européenne comme un facteur de
paix et qui est une valeur qui est très
cher au coeur des adhérents et des
sympathisants du mouvement démocrate
mais aussi ceux de à ceux de la
république en marche donc je pense que
les conditions sont réunies pour que une
liste commune depuis cet constituée
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans les
prochaines semaines mais ce sera dans
les prochaines semaines le 24 janvier
d'ailleurs à viroflay vous organiserez
un débat sur l'europe en présence de
l'eurodéputé à nathalie griesbeck et
aussi du président de la fondation
robert schuman jean-dominique giuliani
il faut continuer de parler de ce
scrutin faire aussi peut-être de la
pédagogie autour d'eux un scrutin qui
est mal connue la 43 % de participation
lors du dernier scrutin
oui vous avez raison je crois qu'il faut
le faire même si une partie de
l'attention va être je dirais attiré par
le grand débat national
les élections européennes de mai 2010
neuf sont un moment décisif parce que
une grande partie de la question de la
souveraineté se joue dans la répartition
des compétences entre l'europe et la
france et donc il faut que en amont de
cette de cette campagne qui va être très
brève à partir de du mois de mars nous
ayons pu déjà avoir un certain nombre de
débats sur ce sujet majeur
merci et jean-noël barrot d'être passé
sur ce plateau je rappelle deuxième
député de la 2e des circonscription des
yvelines également touriste en
secrétaire général du modem merci
d'avoir été avec le savez dans
l'actualité également une enquête
ouverte après la mort d'un ouvrier
à versailles jeudi soir il a perdu la
vie suite à une chute de 18 mètres
cet homme de 68 ans intervenait sur les
toits de la préfecture pour nettoyer les
gouttières et d'après une source proche
de l'affairé citée par nos confrères du
parisien la victime travaillait dans
l'obscurité et sans équipement de
sécurité le préfet jean-jacques brot
s'est dit bouleversé par ce drame il a
rencontré aujourd'hui lé dirigeant de la
société en charge de l'entretien des
toits les travaux ils sont suspendus
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
avant de parler des stylos rouges petite
pause dans ce journal charles aznavour
quitté ce monde le 1er octobre dernier à
l'âge de 94 ans durant sa vie d'artiste
il a vécu dans les yvelines à montfort
l'amaury commune dans laquelle il a été
également enterré depuis de nombreux
touristes se rendent sur sa sépulture un
reportage de nicolas d'andré la vie à
emmener charles aznavour jusqu'au bout
des yvelines à montfort l'amaury le
chanteur franco-arménien repose dans la
sépulture familiale depuis le 6 octobre
de nombreux visiteurs sont venus se
recueillir auprès de leur idole ça
représente à peu près de 100 personnes
par semaine notamment l'office de
tourisme d'arménie véritable office de
taulier d'arménie à organiser
au point tant d'écart pour venir voir
rendre un hommage à south sachant que
c'était quand même une idole en arménie
et en france en situation et dans le
monde
charles aznavour était quand même très
connu dans le monde entier
les nombreux touristes remplissent des
commerces de la place de l'église de la
commune des restaurants font découvert
en plus cette boulangerie a enregistré
une hausse de son chiffre d'affaires on
a eu une grosse période où beaucoup
d'étrangers aussi bon c'était quelqu'un
qui était énormément connu donc par
conséquent c'est un peu logique que les
gens viennent et l'appréciait quoi
surtout montfort l'amaury lieu de
pèlerinage musical à côté de charles
aznavour il est à la maison musée de
maurice ravel et ces journées organisées
au mois d'octobre avec le boléro qui
résonne encore
on parlait tout à l'heure des gilets
jaunes place au stylo rouge dès à
présent un mouvement de professeurs en
colère née sur facebook pour réclamer
notamment de meilleurs salaires et de
meilleures conditions de travail plus de
52000 enseignants ont déjà rejoint le
groupe sur le réseau social bonsoir
delphine romani ont soit vous êtes la
secrétaire du snes fsu des yvelines
syndicat des professeurs du secondaire
déjà une réaction sur ce mouvement sur
le côté spontané sur le côté aussi qu'
il se fasse en dehors de tout syndicat
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
alors ce que ça nous inspire c'est que
c'est un mouvement qui se crée en dehors
de tout syndicat mais qui n'est pas
forcément hostiles au syndicalisme
puisqu'il porte aussi un certain nombre
des revendications que nous nous avons
depuis fort longtemps possédé colère
qu'on entend depuis depuis très
longtemps les meilleures conditions de
travail un des meilleurs salaires tout à
fait des meilleurs des meilleures
conditions de travail un allègement des
effectifs par classe une revalorisation
générale de la profession et de l'image
qu'elle peut avoir dans la société
tout ça ce sont des revendications que
nous partageons avec les stylos rouges
et que nous avons depuis fort longtemps
et que nous portons depuis un certain
nombre d'années
ça témoigne de quoi ce mouvement que les
professeurs se sont oubliés par par la
république oui je crois que ils se sont
sentis oubliés lorsque le président a
fait des annonces et qu'il n'y a pas eu
un seul mot pour les fonctionnaires pour
la fonction publique et pour les
enseignants en particulier et je crois
que c'est ça qui a déclenché cette
colère qui est tout à fait légitime
alors il ya certains professeurs de
l'académie de lille qui est envisagé
aujourd'hui comme action une grève des
corrections m par exemple 20 sur 20 à
toutes les copies est ce que vous savez
si des actions du genre ont lieu
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines si il ya
des actions qui sont programmés dans les
yvelines connaissances pour le moment
très bien donc on se sera à suivre dans
les prochaines semaines alors défini
romani vous êtes venus pour parler avec
nous d'un autre sujet à la rentrée de
septembre
au lycée il y aura cette nouveauté fille
elle les séries l es csl seront
remplacés avec la réforme du bac en tout
cas dans un premier temps pour les
élèves de première à la place un socle
d'enseignement commun pour tout le monde
complété d'un socle did enseignement de
spécialité 3 au choix en 1re 2e en
terminale pour avoir au final une sorte
de bac à la carte qui correspond aux
besoins de chaque élève alors juste
avant les vacances l'académie de
versailles arrive
les son projet de carte des
enseignements des spécialités qui ce
qu'il faut retenir de cette carte
alors c'est un projet de quartier
provisoire quand vous le dit ce n'est
qu'un projet qui a été élaboré en
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales et donc il sera de nouveau
discutée le 17 janvier
donc ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que c'est une
c'est un projet de carte qui va en fait
renforcer un certain nombre de travers
que nous avions déjà dénoncé à propos de
la réforme du lycée blanc caire d'une
part parce que comme vous le disiez les
élèves vont avoir un tronc commun donc
sur la base de 35 élèves et ensuite ils
vont choisir un certain nombre
d'enseignements de spécialité et en fait
c'est ses enseignements de spécialité
vont conduire à renforcer le profil de
certains essais par exemple à renforcer
les enseignements scientifiques au
détriment de tous les enseignements plus
littéraire d humanité langue que tous
les enseignements de spécialité seront
pas disponibles dans tous les lycées du
département ça c'est important de le
préciser ça en théorie tous les
établissements doivent proposer cette
spécialité dites classiques qui sont
l'histoire géographie humanité
littérature et philosophie et lang
mathématiques physique chimie svt et à
suez donc ceux là sont en théorie
proposée par tous les établissements et
ensuite il ya des spécialités dites
rares qui sont arts langues et cultures
de l'antiquité c'est à dire latin grec
sciences de l'ingénieur et une nouvelle
matière qui s'appelle numérique et
sciences de l'informatique d'accord
voilà donc si on regarde dans le détail
en théorie tous ces enseignements donc
les sept spécialités classiques sont
proposés par tous les établissements ce
qui n'est pas le cas en réalité partout
et les enseignements dirar sont proposés
uniquement par certains établissements
lorsque je disais que le caractère
scientifique de l'enseignement va être
renforcée c'est que par exemple si on
prend le cas de l'enseignement hennessy
numérique et sciences de l'informatique
28 établissements vont proposer alors
que seulement cinq établissements des
yvelines vont proposer langues et
cultures de l'antiquité
il ya un déséquilibre sur sur la propre
main sur la répartition on va dire de
ces enseignements de spécialité sur le
territoire voilà ce qu'on voit c'est que
la tendance est à sacrifier les
humanités au profit des sciences
il faut noter également que ça va être
problématique puisque cet enseignement
numérique et sciences de l'informatique
pour l'instant il n'y a aucun professeur
qui est diplômé pour l'enseigné donc
c'était un nouvel enseignement convoi
implantés un peu partout sans avoir
opérait préalable former les professeurs
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
manque de formation vous vous le dites
peut-être un manque d'information des
professeurs sur ce qui va se mettre en
place dès le mois de septembre alors un
manque d'informations je ne sais pas un
manque de formation certainement pour
cet enseignement là en particulier et à
quoi ressemble du coup les journées et
professeurs aujourd'hui le lait est ce
que les les élèves les questionne
beaucoup sur sur cette réforme aussi les
les parents est ce qu'ils peuvent leur
apporter des réponses
alors pour l'instant à les choses sont
en train de se mettre en place les
élèves vont devoir choisir leurs
instruments de spécialités à la fin du
second trimestre qui vont déjà commencé
à formuler des choix qui deviendront
définitifs en fin d'année donc pour
l'instant on est vraiment au tout début
du processus et il ne pose pas encore
trop de questions d'accord alors c'est
en cédant spécialité on le rappelle ils
ont pour objectif selon l'éducation
nationale de garantir au lycée à un
enseignement riche et diversifiée
personnaliser les parcours est renforcée
a les chances de réussite dans le
parcours post bac pour les jeunes voyait
ses enseignements de spécialité
s'afficher à l'écran le ses objectifs
vous en pensez quoi
deux films roumanie le est ce que cette
réforme était nécessaire cette réforme
du bac alors une réforme était
nécessaire ça c'est certain après nous
ce qu'on dit c'est que cette réforme du
lycée on a appelé le lycée des possibles
il ya quand même une grande partie de
communication médiatique j'ai même envie
de dire d'enfumage nous explique que les
élèves vont devoir vont pouvoir choisir
leur parcours mais on sait que c'est
parfait je disais tout à l'heure que
tous les lycées ne pas proposer les
spécialités puisque un certain nombre
d'établissements vont être mises en
réseau donc cela veut dire que les
élèves pourront aller suivre un
enseignement de spécialité dans un autre
établissement qui n'est pas le leur
parce que l'enseignement n'est pas
proposée dans leur établissement
si on prend le cas par exemple de ce qui
se passe à saint germain en laye
donc tous les enseignements de
spécialité vont être proposés dans le
lycée de centre ville le lycée jeanne
d'albret qui est celui qui bénéficie
d'une image plus attractive et les deux
autres lycées de saint germain en laye
le lycée pour que le lycée de vinci ne
pourront pas proposer tous les
enseignements le lycée de vinci va
proposer des enseignements à coloration
plutôt scientifique
le lycée poquelin proposera des
enseignements plus tôt à coloration son
histoire géographie sciences sciences
économiques et sociales mathématiques et
je précise qu'on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien
cette carte sera arrêté le 17 janvier 7
heures d enseignement de spécialité on
arrive malheureusement la fin de cet
entretien merci delphine en roumanie
d'avoir et avignon merci aux prêteurs du
snes fsu des yvelines qu'elles soient
politiques culturelles ou sportives 2018
a été riche en événements tout dans
l'est et dans les yvelines bien sûr
toute cette semaine nous revenons sur
les faits marquants les faits marquants
de l'année dernière pour ce premier
volet focus sur la période janvier à
mars c'est avec au rayon ce le début
d'année 2018 aura été arrosée et froid
dans les yvelines
fin janvier la crue de la seine inonde
le nord du département des pluies qui
laisse place en février à de nombreux
flocons bonsoir à tous mercredi 7
février bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
sur tv 78 édition spéciale ce soir
largement consacré à la neige et ses
répercussions dans le département des
intempéries qui ont paralysé le
territoire transports en commun à
l'arrêt certains automobilistes sont
même restés bloqués toute la nuit sur
les chaussées impraticables
un quotidien perturbé pour les yvelinois
qui ont dû faire preuve d'imagination
pour se déplacer
un début d'année marqué également par la
visite de plusieurs ministres dans notre
département
agnès buzyn ministre des solidarités de
la santé venus à plaisir pour des
rencontres autour de la petite enfance
nous voyons qu'il va falloir intervenir
sur le repérage l'identification des
besoins sur l'axé endroit sur la
formation des professionnels attrape le
tout nouvel institut ellen nanotech
destinés à mesurer l'infiniment petit
est inaugurée en présence de la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie tels fine génie stefan un
déplacement tourner vers les sciences
également pour jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
était en visite au lycée emilie de
breteuil à montigny le bretonneux
un établissement qui propose plusieurs
formations scientifiques
un souhait du gouvernement enfin la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
s'est rendu à méré en ce début d'année
dans un espace dédié aux comores king
c'est une bonne manière de permettre ce
que ce à quoi aspire 61% nos concitoyens
le travail il en était aussi question le
jeudi 29 mars
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a accueilli la
première édition en piste pour l'emploi
au programme rencontres avec des
employeurs échanges avec les entreprises
du territoire
en tout quatre mille offres d'emploi ont
été proposés aux saint quentinois des
saint quentinois qui ont pu emprunter
dès le mois de mars la toute nouvelle
route départementale 30 à plaisir après
trois ans de travaux la deux fois deux
voies est enfin ouverte
c'est la base même d'une femme
qui et les fondamentaux pour que notre
ville puisse avoir des aspirations
encore supplémentaires dans un
développement à la fois commercial
économique et à cadre de vie pour
emprunter la ligne 18 il faudra en
revanche encore attendre la nouvelle
tombe en février la livraison du premier
tronçon est retardé arrivé au plus tard
en 2027 sur le plateau de saclay et non
plus en 2024
[Musique]
sur le plan culturel en janvier le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
a fêté ses 30 ans depuis trois décennies
l'établissement versailles et heures à
la valorisation du patrimoine musical
des xviie et xviiie siècles lui a laissé
le temps d'une soirée la musique pour
déclamer les grands discours qui ont
fait l'histoire de l'assemblée nationale
début 2018 joey starr était à l'affiché
du théâtre montansier à versailles pour
éloquence à l'assemblée côté la peine de
mort vous voilà force et forcé encore
des bouts de taux si l'union c'est la
misère enfin le premier trimestre 2010 8
a également été sportif avec du cyclisme
et le départ le 4 mars dans les yvelines
de la 76e édition du paris-nice et
déception samedi 6 janvier pour l'équipe
de rouille le club de foot y vino à
chute en 32e de finale de la coupe de
france de football battu 3 buts à 0 par
concarneau
près de 2000 supporters étaient venus
encourager le petit poucet de la
compétition un match sans enjeu en
revanche le samedi 24 mars dans
l'enceinte du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'anciennes
gloires du psg se sont affrontés pour la
bonne cause
le 15e trophée du gol de letra trophée
créé par rail afin de récolter des dons
en faveur des enfants défavorisés
brésilien et après 2018 2019 devrait
encore marquer les esprits en tout cas
du côté du sport bonsoir amitié les
littoraux sans galerie très bonne année
2010 neuf et surtout une année sportive
on l'espère du sport merci michael peu
d'années avoue également en 2018 il eut
la ryder cup
évidemment à saint quentin en yvelines
est ce que 2019 sera aussi un bon cru
niveau sport alors il va y avoir du
sport en 2019 un grégory cette année
marque ragnotti
le retour du jumping de versailles après
avoir annulé l'édition 2018 faute de
date disponible les organisateurs ont
programmé ce concours hippique de sauts
d'obstacles international du 26 au 28
avril en face du château
autre retour après 20 ans d'absence les
championnats de france féminin par
équipes nationales de gymnastique
reviennent en ile de france la
compétition sera organisée au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous avions reçu l'une des
organisatrices sur ce plateau
on attend mille quatre cents gymnastes
sur les trois jours qui seront qui font
la collection et on espère atteindre
5000 personnes
sur ces événements spectateurs alors pas
de ryder cup mais il y aura encore du
golfe cette année dans les yvelines je
peux rien vous cacher un ou qui est un
golf hors pair un des gorille l'open de
france sera une nouvelle fois organisé
sur le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette année le
rendez vous ne sera pas programmé fin
juin mais du 17 au 20 octobre il devient
l'avant dernier tournoi de la saison en
europe
on écoute le dtn du golf français
christophe muniesa l'open de france en
juin a pu souffrir par le passé d'une
trop grande proximité de dates avec
roland garros où avec le tour de france
ou avec le rôle mondial de foot
donc on pense qu'en étant remplacé en
deuxième partie de saison là on a un
coup à jouer si on peut dire il y aura
enfin du cyclisme de haut niveau sur le
territoire pour la dixième année
consécutive le paris-nice s'élancera des
yvelines 10 mars
le parcours sera officiellement dévoilé
ce mercredi 9 janvier toujours sur la
route rambouillet sera ville départ sur
la 26e et dernière étape du tour de
france le dimanche 26 juillet plus de
40000 spectateurs sont attendus pour
l'événement enfin le stadium de bmx de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines recevra deux
manches du circuit de coupe du monde et
de coupe de france les 8 et 10 juin
prochains exercices michael est dans
votre étude pour toute à l'heure encore
plus de grands rendez-vous pour 2019
dans le département toujours au sport
diana il y en a beaucoup c'est arrivé
après ce journal qui touche d'ailleurs à
sa fin vous pouvez retrouver le replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile belle soirée avec
télé 78
[Musique]